This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We have one cardinal rule on 99% Invisible. No cardinals. Meaning, we don't deal with the natural world, only the built world. So when I read John Mwellen's brilliant book called Wild Ones, a sometimes dismaying, weirdly reassuring story about looking at people looking at animals in America.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在《99% Invisible》我们有一条基本准则：没有“基本”（cardinal，意为红雀/基本）。意思是，我们不涉及自然界，只关注人造世界。所以，当我读到约翰·穆勒姆那本精彩的《野性之辈》（Wild Ones）时——那是一个关于观察美国人如何观察动物的故事，有时令人沮丧，却又有一种奇怪的慰藉感。
I didn't think I'd ever do an episode of 99% of Isabel about it. I just read it for fun. But then I saw John perform stories from the book Live with musical accompaniment and I thought, I need to put this on the radio. I still call this radio. Anyway, what you need to know about Wild Ones is that it isn't a book about nature. It's a book about how we fit nature into our modern lives. Wild Ones is about the cutesy stuffed animals, the eco-tours, and the Byzantine methods
我从没想过会为它做一期《99% Invisible》。我只是为了消遣而读。但后来我看到约翰现场表演书中的故事，并配有音乐伴奏，我想，我得把它搬上电台。我还是习惯称之为电台。总之，关于《野性之辈》，你需要知道的是，它不是一本关于自然的书。它是一本关于我们如何将自然融入现代生活的书。《野性之辈》讲述的是可爱的毛绒玩具、生态旅游，以及那些拜占庭式的
of conservation that evolve when our experience with wildlife goes from something natural to something designed. Human animal interaction has become a designed experience. And the story of that transition, as the title of the book suggests, is sometimes dismayed, and also weirdly reassuring. John Mwellem is friends with the band Black Prairie, and as he was writing the book, they can talk to this idea of the band creating a soundtrack writing the book, they concocted this idea of the band creating a soundtrack to the book, and the result was an extended EP called Wild Ones. A musical score for the things you might see in your head when you reflect on certain
保护方法，这些方法在我们与野生动物的互动从自然体验转变为设计体验时应运而生。人与动物的互动已经成为一种被设计的体验。正如书名所暗示的那样，这种转变的故事有时令人沮丧，但也有一种奇怪的慰藉感。约翰·穆勒姆与“黑草原”（Black Prairie）乐队是朋友，当他在写书时，他们萌生了乐队为书创作原声带的想法，结果是一张名为《野性之辈》的加长版EP。这是一段音乐配乐，当你反思书中读到的某些
characters and incidents that you read in the book. The writer and the band then went on a short tour with the song and story extravaganza that I'm going to play for you today. When I saw them perform this live in San Francisco, I freaked out it was so good and I 2 %, 1 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd
人物和事件时，你脑海中可能会浮现出这些画面。随后，作家和乐队带着这个歌曲与故事的盛宴进行了短途巡演，我今天就要为你播放这段内容。当我在旧金山现场看到他们的表演时，我简直惊呆了，太棒了，我……
2 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful. I'm going to be a little bit more careful.
我会再小心一点。我会再小心一点。我会再小心一点。
I'm going to be a little bit more careful. The It happens every summer. Small turtles called Diamondback Tarotans skitter out of the water around JFK Airport in New York. They start moving west. They're heading for a patch of sand where they like to lay their eggs, and they have to cross over one of the airport's runways to get their runway for L. Sometimes there's so many turtles on the move at wants that the control tower has to delay flights. Now the press loves doing stories about how funny this is, how a fleet of giant airplanes can be held up by just a few tiny turtles.
我会再小心一点。每年夏天都会发生这样的事。一种叫作钻纹龟的小海龟会从纽约肯尼迪机场附近的水域爬出来。它们开始向西移动。它们正前往一片它们喜欢产卵的沙地，而为了到达那里，它们必须穿过机场的一条跑道。有时，同时移动的海龟太多，控制塔不得不推迟航班。现在，媒体很喜欢报道这有多滑稽，成群的巨型飞机竟然会被几只小海龟阻挡。
But hold that picture in your mind and think about the Caribbean Sea in 1492. There were almost a billion sea turtles living in it back then. Columbus's man anchored in the Caribbean wrote about being kept awake at night by the thwacking of so many turtle shells against the sides of their ship. Notice how that scene is the exact opposite of the scene at JFK. It's not a fleet of giant airplanes being held up by a few tiny turtles. It's not a fleet of giant airplanes being held up by a few tiny turtles. It's a giant fleet of turtles bombarding just a few relatively tiny ships. So I wrote this book about people and wild animals in America and it only really started
但请在脑海中保持这个画面，想想1492年的加勒比海。那时海里生活着近十亿只海龟。哥伦布的船员在加勒比海抛锚时，写道他们晚上被无数海龟壳撞击船体的声音吵得无法入睡。注意这个场景与肯尼迪机场的场景恰恰相反。这不是成群的巨型飞机被几只小海龟阻挡。这是一个巨大的海龟群在轰炸几艘相对较小的船只。所以我写了这本关于美国人与野生动物的书，它最初的起因
because I wanted to show my daughter in endangered species in the wild before they disappeared. Like a lot of people I think I felt this pain. I knew that all around us beautiful parts of the world are expiring. And I also knew that people in the future, they might not even notice. For them, a world without whales or wilderness might feel normal. I wanted to counteract that forgetting that's bound to take hold over time. This forgetting has a name. Scientists call it shifting baselines in Rome.
仅仅是因为我想在濒危物种消失前，带我的女儿去野外看看它们。像许多人一样，我想我感受到了这种痛苦。我知道在我们周围，世界上美好的部分正在消亡。我也知道未来的人们可能根本不会注意到。对他们来说，一个没有鲸鱼或荒野的世界可能感觉很正常。我想抵消这种注定会随时间而产生的遗忘。这种遗忘有一个名字。科学家称之为“基线偏移”。
It means that all of us accept the version of the world we inherit as normal. Over the years we watch forests get locked or animals disappear, but when the next generation comes along, they accept that depleted version of nature as they're normal. It's hard to zoom out, really feel the changes that are stacking up across the generations. I can't even imagine what an ocean filled with a billion sea turtles unless feel I. Last winter, I was in Hawaii, and I saw three sea turtles,
这意味着我们所有人都接受了我们继承的那个版本的世界作为常态。多年来，我们看着森林被砍伐或动物消失，但当下一代出现时，他们接受了那个退化的自然版本作为他们的常态。很难跳出来，真正感受到几代人以来不断累积的变化。我甚至无法想象一个充满十亿只海龟的海洋是什么样子。去年冬天，我在夏威夷，我看到了三只海龟，
and I flipped the f*** out. I felt like I was in Eden. It wasn't so long ago, though, that America was a kind of eat. When people could be dwarfed and engulfed by wild animals in a way that feels almost impossible now. In the late 1800s, trains with sometimes had to stop for four or five hours as streams of buffalo moved across the tracks. Occasionally, a stampede would batter into the side of a train derailing it. A witness described one of these scenes, 1871 in Kansas. Each individual a buffalo went at it, with the desperation and despair of punching against the green locomotive cars, just as blind madness changed directed after having
我简直疯了。我觉得自己置身于伊甸园。然而，不久前，美国还是一种伊甸园。那时人们会被野生动物淹没，那种感觉在今天几乎是不可能的。在19世纪末，火车有时不得不停下来四五个小时，因为成群的野牛穿过铁轨。偶尔，兽群会撞击火车侧面，导致火车脱轨。一位目击者描述了1871年堪萨斯州发生的一幕：每一头野牛都带着绝望和疯狂，撞向绿色的火车头，就像盲目的疯狂在……
trains thrown off the track twice a week, conductors learned to have a very decided respect for the idiosyncrasies of the buffalo. This man's name was William Temple Horneday. He was a bombastic midwesterner with an elaborate mustache. Horneday was head-taxidermist at the Smithsonian and he traveled the globe, hunting exotic animals and stuffing them for the museum. In India, after he took down an elephant, we climbed to top the carcass and popped open a bass ale.
在火车每周两次被撞出轨道后，列车员学会了对野牛的怪癖保持一种非常坚定的尊重。这个人的名字叫威廉·坦普尔·霍纳迪。他是一个有着精致胡须、夸夸其谈的中西部人。霍纳迪是史密森尼学会的首席标本剥制师，他周游世界，猎杀珍奇动物并将它们制成标本供博物馆陈列。在印度，在他击倒一头大象后，我们爬上尸体，打开了一瓶淡啤酒。
Once he trapped in a rangatang, named it Little Man, and gave it to Andrew Carnegie as a pet. It sounds weird, but for Hornetay, killing these animals was a kind of conservation. He believed by stuffing them, he was preserving endangered species and for the future generations that might not know them after they were gone. Through taxidermy, he could make them immortal. In 1886, Horneday looked west and saw that Americans were killing so many buffaloes, so rapidly, that the prairie was almost empty.
有一次，他捕获了一只红毛猩猩，给它取名“小人”，并把它作为宠物送给了安德鲁·卡内基。这听起来很奇怪，但对霍纳迪来说，猎杀这些动物是一种保护。他相信通过制作标本，他是在为那些在它们消失后可能不了解它们的后代保存濒危物种。通过标本剥制术，他可以让它们永生。1886年，霍纳迪向西望去，发现美国人猎杀野牛的速度太快，以至于草原几乎空了。
He figured there were maybe less than 300 buffalo left in the wild. And so he did what he thought was the most helpful and logical thing. He lit out for Montana to kill several dozen of them. ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy
他估计野外可能剩下不到300头野牛。于是他做了他认为最有帮助、最合乎逻辑的事情。他前往蒙大拿州猎杀了数十头。我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人。
I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy I'm not a bad guy, I'm not a bad guy La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la One day, he shot 25 buffalo in Montana and he built the best looking ones into an exhibit at the museum. He gathered them around a thick, watering hole, looking for lorne. But from there, his thinking evolved. He realized he was basically just a funeral director, embalming the species that America was exterminating. It occurred to him.
我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人，我不是坏人。啦啦啦……有一天，他在蒙大拿州射杀了25头野牛，并将其中最好看的几头做成了博物馆的展品。他把它们聚集在一个茂密的水坑周围，看起来很凄凉。但从那时起，他的想法发生了演变。他意识到自己基本上只是一个殡仪馆馆长，在为美国正在灭绝的物种进行防腐处理。他突然想到：
What if we actually tried to keep these animals alive? And so he became one of America's first real wildlife conservationists, an activist, a lobbyist, a celebrity. America was killing every conceivable kind of animal in their way and Hornet Day stood up for all of them, and micons like the Grizzly, to lowlier, less majestic things, like the squirrel. A live squirrel in a tree is poetry in motion.
如果我们真的尝试让这些动物活下去会怎样？于是他成为了美国第一批真正的野生动物保护主义者之一，一名活动家、游说者、名人。美国正在猎杀挡在路上的每一种可以想象到的动物，而霍纳迪站出来为它们所有人辩护，从灰熊这样的大型动物，到松鼠这样卑微、不那么雄伟的生物。树上的一只活松鼠是运动中的诗歌。
We ask every American to let the hand to stay the silver tail. There was really only one animal on the continent that Hornetay wasn't worried about. It would seem too mighty to be brought down by men with guns and it lived in a cold and brutal wilderness that men couldn't possibly take over. Polar Bear was the king of the frozen North! It's not very probable that the Polar Bear will ever be exterminated by man. That's Hornet A writing in 1914. Back then, no one could have imagined a problem as abstract as climate change.
我们请求每一位美国人伸出援手，留下那条银色的尾巴。大陆上其实只有一种动物是霍纳迪不担心的。它看起来太强大了，不可能被拿着枪的人类击倒，而且它生活在一个人类不可能占领的寒冷而残酷的荒野中。北极熊是冰封北方的国王！北极熊不太可能被人类灭绝。这是霍纳迪1914年写的。那时，没有人能想象出气候变化这样抽象的问题。
But think about how quickly climate change has changed the polar bear's reputation in our minds. It's gone from bloodthirsty man killer to delicate drowning victim. 200 years ago, Arctic explorers wrote about polar bears leaping into their boats and trying to eat them, even if they lit the bear on fire. But recently when I went to the tiny northern town that calls itself the polar bear a capital of the world, Martha Stewart had just arrived to film the animals for her daytime show on the hallmark channel. The town is called Churchill Manitoba. It's on the edge of Hudson Bay and every fall, right before the bay freezes over. Churchill gets overrun with about 900 polar bears and 10,000 polar bear tourists.
但想想气候变化在我们的心目中改变北极熊的形象有多快。它已经从嗜血的人类杀手变成了脆弱的溺水受害者。200年前，北极探险家写道，北极熊会跳进他们的船并试图吃掉他们，即使他们点火烧熊。但最近，当我去了那个自称“世界北极熊之都”的北方小镇时，玛莎·斯图尔特刚刚抵达，为她在霍尔马克频道的日间节目拍摄这些动物。这个小镇叫丘吉尔，曼尼托巴省。它位于哈德逊湾的边缘，每年秋天，就在海湾结冰之前，丘吉尔就会挤满大约900只北极熊和10,000名北极熊游客。
Bears routinely wander into town. They like hanging out at the elementary school, especially. Folks can call 675 Bearer, and a squad of bear patrol officers will come chase the animals back onto the tundra and their trucks. Bearers that won't budge are tranquilized and shipped out to a quonset hunt near the airport. Once this so-called polar bear jail fills up, each animal is drugged again, and airlifted one at a time to an area north of town. Crowds of tourists come out to watch these bear lifts and I went to one myself. There was something just a little ceremonial about the bear lift I went to. How the uniformed wildlife officers arranged the sleeping bear on a net at the center of
熊经常会溜进镇里。它们特别喜欢在小学附近闲逛。人们可以拨打675-BEAR，一支熊巡逻队就会赶来，用卡车把动物赶回苔原。那些不肯挪窝的熊会被麻醉，并被运送到机场附近的一个波纹钢棚里。一旦这个所谓的“北极熊监狱”满了，每只动物会被再次注射药物，并一次一只地空运到镇北的一个区域。成群的游客会出来观看这些“运熊”过程，我自己也去过一次。我参加的那次运熊过程有一种仪式感。身穿制服的野生动物官员小心翼翼地把沉睡的熊安置在中心的网兜上，
the crowd. How they tucked its paws carefully across its chest like some drunken uncle after Thanksgiving dinner. It was so careful, beautiful, and confusing. A couple of people cried. It was like the opposite of an animal sacrifice, a ritual to save the bearer, to show how far out of our way we'd go not to kill it. I stood there and watched, and as I did, Martha Stewart stood next to me. Her crew was there filming everything. Honestly, it's a breathtaking thing to watch, a polar bear fly away. All of a sudden the helicopters started to churn, the edges of the net lifted.
就像感恩节晚餐后喝醉的叔叔一样，把它的爪子小心地交叉在胸前。这太小心、太美丽、太令人困惑了。几个人哭了。这就像是动物祭祀的反面，一种拯救熊的仪式，展示了我们为了不杀它愿意付出多大的努力。我站在那里看着，玛莎·斯图尔特就站在我旁边。她的摄制组在那里拍摄一切。老实说，看着北极熊飞走是一件令人叹为观止的事情。突然间，直升机开始轰鸣，网兜的边缘升起。
The furry shape inside contracted to you and then the entire package was off the ground. The helicopter climbed toward a cloud bank, the bear twirling slightly underneath it like a teethe bag, and then finally the polar bear was gone. Yeah, I know, air lifting polar bears. Strange, no one could have imagined it would come to this. But the way we help animals now has evolved into a surreal kind of performance art. We carry migrating salmanners across busy highways, we monitor pygmy rabbits with drones. At Cornell, scientists breeding endangered parygrine falcons were especially made receptacle they called the Cocholation House, coaxed the bird named Beercan, to ejaculate on
里面的毛茸茸形状收缩了一下，然后整个包裹就离开了地面。直升机向云层爬升，熊在下面轻轻旋转，像个茶包，最后北极熊消失了。是的，我知道，空运北极熊。很奇怪，没人能想到会变成这样。但我们现在帮助动物的方式已经演变成一种超现实的表演艺术。我们把迁徙的鲑鱼运过繁忙的高速公路，我们用无人机监测侏儒兔。在康奈尔大学，科学家们培育濒危的游隼，在一个他们称之为“合作屋”的特殊容器里，诱导一只名叫“啤酒罐”的鸟，在20世纪70年代的大部分时间里，每天多次在他们的头上射精。
their heads several times a day every day for much of the 1970s. See this is another baseline that shifts over time. The lengths we're willing to go. Each generation does what would have looked like fighting for a preposterous lost cause to the one before, and then each generation comes along anew and does a little bit more than that. Non-agodes, humanity, strapping on the proverbberal population now, again and again and again. Consider the story of George and Tex. The late 1970s, there were only a handful of looping cranes left in the wild, and also
看，这是另一个随时间推移而偏移的基线。我们愿意付出的努力。每一代人所做的事情，在上一代人看来就像是在为一场荒谬的失败事业而战，然后每一代人又重新开始，做得比上一代多一点。人类，一次又一次地承担起这个重任。考虑一下乔治和特克斯的故事。20世纪70年代末，野外只剩下少数几只美洲鹤，
a small number at a government lab in Maryland. Scientists there were doing their best to ring as many new offspring as they could from those captive birds. But the lab had one problem, child, a female crane named Tex. As a newborn Tex had been raised in a cardboard box in the zookeeper's living room, and having never seen another crane, she imprinted on the one animal she did see the zookeeper. Basically, she wound up sexually attracted to people and not other cranes. The scientists kept trying to pair a Tex off but text wasn't interested. She wanted a man,
马里兰州的一个政府实验室里也有少量。那里的科学家尽最大努力从那些圈养的鸟类中繁育出尽可能多的后代。但实验室有一个问题，特克斯，一只名叫特克斯的雌性鹤。作为新生儿，特克斯是在动物园管理员客厅里的一个纸板箱中长大的，由于从未见过其他鹤，她对她唯一见过的动物——动物园管理员——产生了印记。基本上，她最终对人产生了性吸引力，而不是对其他鹤。科学家们一直试图给特克斯配对，但特克斯不感兴趣。她想要一个男人，
and specifically a man who looked like her old zookeeper, a dark-haired white man, a medium-build. Now, there was a young crane conservationist named George Archibald and George happened to be a dark-haired white man, a medium-build. He took text to rural Wisconsin, put a mattress in her pen, and moved in as Texas companion. They'd forge together, build a nest, and they'd dance. George, during deep knee bends and springing up with thorns out like wings, He'd wook, then holler, come on, text, come on, come on,
特别是那种看起来像她以前的动物园管理员的男人，一个深色头发、中等身材的白人。当时，有一位年轻的鹤类保护主义者名叫乔治·阿奇博尔德，乔治恰好是一个深色头发、中等身材的白人。他把特克斯带到威斯康星州的农村，在她的围栏里放了一张床垫，并搬进去作为特克斯的伴侣。他们一起觅食、筑巢，还会跳舞。乔治做深蹲，像翅膀一样伸出双臂跳起，他会鸣叫，然后大喊：“来吧，特克斯，来吧，来吧，”
Come on, text, and soon, they'd be dancing together just like wild cranes do during courtship. This would get Tex aroused, and it just the right moment to assistance would rush out from a hiding place an artificially inseminator with cranes even. George did all this for three years, living with texts for months at a time because the eggs she kept laying were infertile. The man in crane would start out after dawn, they'd go for a walk, and they'd dance, they'd dance, and they'd dance, and they dance, they dance, and they dance, and they dance. George didn't enjoy any of this. He was miserable, actually miserable.
“来吧，特克斯，”很快，他们就会像野鹤求偶时那样一起跳舞。这会让特克斯兴奋起来，就在合适的时机，助手会从藏身处冲出来，甚至用人工授精的方式给鹤受精。乔治做了这一切三年，每次和特克斯住上几个月，因为她不断产下的蛋都是未受精的。男人和鹤在黎明后出发，他们去散步，他们跳舞，他们跳舞，他们跳舞……乔治并不享受这一切。他很痛苦，实际上非常痛苦。
But in the spring of 1983, text finally laid an egg that hatched, and George was right there when it did. He was invited on the tonight show to celebrate one headline read, man, crangy, proud parents of Chick. George named the Chick-ih-Wiz. By now, G-Wiz has 44 grandchildren and great grandchildren. Today, there are more woping grains in the wild than there have been in almost a hundred years. William Temple Horned Day, the taxidermist, died in 1937. At his funeral, buglers from the local Boy Scout troop surrounded the coffin and played
但在1983年的春天，特克斯终于产下了一枚孵化成功的蛋，乔治就在现场。他被邀请参加《今夜秀》庆祝。一个标题写道：“男人、鹤，小鸡的骄傲父母”。乔治给这只小鸡取名“G-Wiz”。到目前为止，G-Wiz已经有了44个孙辈和曾孙辈。今天，野外美洲鹤的数量比过去近一百年里的任何时候都要多。威廉·坦普尔·霍纳迪，那位标本剥制师，于1937年去世。在他的葬礼上，当地童子军的号手围在棺材旁吹奏了
home on the range. Twenty years later, workers at the Smithsonian were dismantling Horneday's buffalo exhibit, the one he built after the hunt in Montana, the one he thought would last forever. They found a rusty box buried in the fake ground. Inside was a letter. It was from Horniday, written to his future successor at the museum. Dear sir, what I am Dustin Ashes, I beg you to protect these specimens from the deterioration of destruction.
《家在草原》（Home on the Range）。二十年后，史密森尼学会的工作人员正在拆除霍纳迪的野牛展品，就是他在蒙大拿州狩猎后建造的那个，他以为会永远保存下去的那个。他们在假地面下发现了一个生锈的盒子。里面有一封信。那是霍纳迪写的，写给他博物馆未来的继任者。亲爱的先生，我已化为尘土，恳请您保护这些标本免受腐烂和破坏。
At last, the game butchers of the Great West have stopped killing the buffalo. All the buffalo are dead. Hello, my name is William Temple, please know I tried, I tried dear sir I write this letter to you, relevant Give the devil his doom. Dear, sir, I am happy not to be alive To see what you have to say dear sir, I have protected them now to thee. Highest degree, dear Son, I have now stopped the killing, they're all gone We're here for you to see I'm giving them a home. Please keep them from home.
终于，大西部的屠夫们停止了猎杀野牛。所有的野牛都死了。你好，我叫威廉·坦普尔，请知道我尽力了，我尽力了，亲爱的先生，我写这封信给你，让魔鬼得到他的报应。亲爱的先生，我很高兴我没活着看到你要说的话，亲爱的先生，我已经保护了它们，现在交给你了。最高程度，亲爱的先生，我已经停止了杀戮，它们都走了，我在这里让你看到，我给了它们一个家。请保护它们免受伤害。
I am dust and bone. You can move faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than faster than can move faster than faster than the wild ones can I'll give now I am the stand-up, you can do faster than of Of course Hornet Ed written that pessimistic letter in 1887 when he was still just a young taxidermist. Turns out he was wrong, the buffalo were not all dead, and in the years to come he actually played a big role in helping to save them. Lots of other species too. But it was hard for him to focus on those successes. He'd lost so many more battles than he wanted. By the end of his life, he'd turn bitter to solution. I tried to inject the courage into the hearts of men, but today, I think that speaking generally, civilized man is an unmitigated ass. Like all of us, his imagination was hopelessly trapped in its own moment, its own lifetime.
我已化为尘土和骨头。你移动得比野性之辈更快……当然，霍纳迪在1887年他还是个年轻的标本剥制师时写下了那封悲观的信。事实证明他错了，野牛并没有全部灭绝，在随后的几年里，他在帮助拯救它们方面确实发挥了重要作用。还有许多其他物种也是。但他很难专注于那些成功。他输掉的战斗比他想要的要多得多。在他生命的尽头，他变得痛苦而幻灭。“我试图将勇气注入人们的心中，但今天，我认为总的来说，文明人是一个彻头彻尾的蠢货。”像我们所有人一样，他的想象力无可救药地被困在自己的时代，自己的一生中。
You can only see the world through the tiny keyhole of the present. So, where does that leave us then, in our present? Maybe all any one of us can do is push against the baseline as it shifts. We can be a tiny counterweight. We weigh almost nothing. The generation after generation that weight adds up. Sometimes in some places the baseline starts to shift in the other direction. In the direction of more being, not less. But that happens in Cremenoi 2 and it can be hard to notice. So picture that scene at JFK again, all those turtles. When Hornet it was born, they were close to extinction, being hunted because they tasted so good and soup.
你只能通过当下的微小钥匙孔看世界。那么，这把我们留在了哪里，在我们的当下？也许我们每个人能做的就是推动基线偏移。我们可以成为一个微小的配重。我们几乎没有重量。一代又一代，这种重量累积起来。有时在某些地方，基线开始向另一个方向偏移。向着更多生命的方向，而不是更少。但这发生得很缓慢，而且很难察觉。所以再次想象肯尼迪机场的那个场景，那些海龟。当霍纳迪出生时，它们濒临灭绝，因为它们在汤里味道鲜美而被猎杀。
We're like those turtles. The race of stubborn little things that barely notices as the wilderness it migrates through fills up with villages and lights and swells into an airport runway. Just keep migrating across it anyway, talking the eggs of the next generation into the sand. And we're like the airplanes soon, because we have chains. We've changed into something that Hornetay couldn't ever imagine. Species that can at least try to slow down.
我们就像那些海龟。那种顽强的小生物，在它迁徙的荒野中，随着村庄、灯光和机场跑道的扩张，几乎没有察觉。无论如何，只是继续穿过它，把下一代的蛋埋进沙子里。我们就像飞机，因为我们有链条。我们已经变成了霍纳迪无法想象的东西。一个至少可以尝试减速的物种。
Try to stop. I like to think about those airplanes powering down. The lines are then partying like a shiny metallic scene. So this tiny tribe of turtles in Pasquim. I get it. It looks funny in the present, but squint into the hazy panorama of history and those airplanes idling in place, that little moment of not moving forward, looks unmistakably to me like progress. La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la I'm gonna love you, I'm gonna love you I'm gonna love you, I'm gonna love you
尝试停下来。我喜欢想象那些飞机减速的样子。那些线条像闪亮的金属场景一样分开。所以这群在机场的小海龟。我明白了。在当下看起来很滑稽，但眯起眼睛看向历史那朦胧的全景，那些停在原地的飞机，那一小段不向前移动的时刻，在我看来无疑是进步。我将爱你，我将爱你，我将爱你，我将爱你。
Thank you guys for my great love I'm gonna love you, I'm gonna love you Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, text written by John Moelleum, music by Black Prairie. Black Prairie is Jenny Conley Driesos on accordion invocals. Chris Funk on Banjo Dobro on a harp and vocals. John Moin on drums and vocals. John Newfeld on drums and vocals, John Newfeld on guitar and vocals, Nate Query on bass, and Anelisa Tornfeld on Fiddling Vocals. Their recording engineer is Rich Hip.
谢谢你们，我的大爱，我将爱你，我将爱你……《野性之辈》由约翰·穆勒姆撰写，音乐由“黑草原”乐队创作。“黑草原”乐队成员包括：珍妮·康利·德里索斯（手风琴和人声）、克里斯·芬克（班卓琴、多布罗吉他、竖琴和人声）、约翰·莫因（鼓和人声）、约翰·纽菲尔德（吉他和人声）、内特·奎里（贝斯）以及安丽莎·托恩菲尔德（小提琴和人声）。他们的录音工程师是里奇·希普。
That's 99% Invisible for this week, the show is Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. We are a project of KLW-991.7 local public radio in in San Francisco in the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. Sam Greensman tweets at Sam listens. We have links to all things Wild Ones at our website, it'sepia.org Radio Tepia from PRX There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是本周的《99% Invisible》，节目制作人是萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山KLW-991.7当地公共广播电台和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并关注这个节目。我在Twitter上是@RomanMars。萨姆·格林斯潘在Twitter上是@SamListens。我们的网站epia.org上有关于《野性之辈》的所有链接。来自PRX的Radio Tepia。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。